This money is to get
my wizness -
woman-owned business -
up and running.
Oh, you mean phone wigs?
I'm using mine right now.
Yeah!
I mean, Ilana in real life -
every once in a while,
she'll, like, wear a wig
to a party.
I love wigs. I love hair.
This is the kind of wig you get
buried in.
In prior seasons,
Ilana's had, like, wigs sewn
into the back of her helmet.
Or do you wanna tell 'em...
I kept Abbi's stunt double wig
to just wear and be her.
So weird.
Wigs!
Ilana's Phone Wigs -
they are a key prop
from this season.
They were designed and created
by Marcel Dagenais,
our key hair guy.
Phone wigs have
never been made before,
so it was a lot of engineering
to figure it out.
Honestly, I wouldn't
normally do this,
but I believe
it pitched it.
And then it was like...
Another wigs invention?
It's the same as the helmet.
We were like...
Yeah. But it's -
I guess it's a theme.
But it's so funny.
And then we like...
So stupid.
went nuts with, like,
who she would make.
There's one for Abbi...
Ilana... That's Lincoln...
Jaimé...
This one was made out of a wig
that Ilana wore in Season 4.
That's the Ross... The Rachel...
Gunther, from “Friends”...
That's Michelle Obama...
And, uh, Bernadette Peters.
A lot of times, I'll see them
on camera and I'm like, “Ah!”
You know? So
usually, I ask props
to bring 'em by me
to get a little coif,
to do a little pick.
The Ilana ones, anyways.
Wizness!